all right guys so some totally
game-changing
iphone 12 leaks were revealed overnight
from the absolute most reliable apple
leaker out there
which is kang with a 97.8 accuracy
rating
according to appletrak.org and on top of
that john prosser gave us some very
disappointing updates on the air tags
and
the airpods studio and we also have some
new information
that confirms my thoughts on when we
should be seeing the first apple silicon
max get revealed
so i'll get into that after the iphone
12 leaks so what i'm gonna do in this
video
is not just list off all of the leaks
but i'm gonna try to explain
the context so you're not misinformed
and i'm going to try to explain how
certain features are going to work and
how it's ultimately going to affect you
on the day-to-day so let's get right
into it kang
is a chinese leaker who uses weibo and
apparently
he somehow gained access to apple's
pre-recorded video
for their october event so let's get
started with the homepod mini
kang says it's getting announced next
week and it's basically going to be 3.3
inches tall over two times shorter
than the regular homepod which is seven
inches tall it's gonna come with the
same chip
as the apple watch se and orders are
gonna begin on november 6th
as far as the iphone 12 there's going to
be four models
the same ones you've already heard about
but the price of the mini
will be 699 dollars which is actually
quite pricey
and what's interesting is that the
iphone 12 pro is only 200 dollars more
expensive
than the regular 6.1 inch 12 and it's
supposed to come
with double the storage so it's actually
not that bad of a deal in comparison
as far as the colors the low end models
are getting new blue and green
finishes and the pro models are getting
graphite
which seems to be just a darker space
gray
and they're getting a new midnight blue
color now what's totally shocking
is that in the united states all four
models are getting
millimeter wave 5g not just the pro
models
and as expected no earphones or
chargers in the box apple is also coming
out with a new
smart data mode feature which basically
switches between using 4g
and 5g on the fly so it saves battery
life by using 4g
or sub 6 5g which is basically just
glorified 4g
and then if your city supports it it
then switches
to 5g if you actually need it even more
shocking is that each model is
supposedly getting
the same super retina xdr display
that means the same crazy good oled
displays
capable of viewing hdr content are going
into the lower end iphones
on top of that each model is getting a
new ceramic
substrate glass screen which is actually
quite exciting
because if you know anything about the
apple watch the ceramic models are
incredibly scratch resistant so i guess
we're gonna have to see
how good it is apple is now rebranding
their wireless charging to
magsafe which is what they used to call
their mac chargers
which attached magnetically keeping it
safe for kids
who would otherwise trip over a charging
cable it's gonna have
up to 15 watts of charging power and
instead of reviving air power
apple is coming out with two mag safe
charging pads
the single and the duo which also
support
various airpods as well on top of that
they're coming out with
brand new iphone cases with built-in
mag safe magnets so your iphone will
quickly snap into place
right onto your charging pad and i'm
sure they're going to release versions
of this new case
for older iphone models as well to make
more sales
now the most interesting part about all
of this is the cameras on the new iphone
12 models
both of the less expensive iphone 12s
are getting dual cameras just like they
did last year
but the wide camera is getting an
upgraded sensor
and a new lens with a faster f 1.6
aperture and a new seven layer lens
design
kang also mentioned that everything from
deep fusion
night mode and smart hdr is getting
upgraded
this means that the new wide camera
sensor is going to be faster at reading
out
and combined with the new a14 chip it's
going to be able to take
combine and process photos much faster
than the iphone 11 lineup
thus improving all of those features now
let's move on to the pro models
which is where the most misinformation
is happening right now
kang said that the iphone 12 pro can
provide up to four times
optical zoom and the pro max can provide
up to five times optical zoom this
doesn't actually mean that the telephoto
lens is going to become telescopic
just like on the samsung flagships he
actually means
the total difference in optical zoom so
on the pro
if the ultra wide lens uses a 13
millimeter focus length
and the telephoto lens uses a 52
millimeter focus length
that's actually a four times difference
hence the 4x optical zoom and according
to king
the pro max is getting a 65 millimeter
focus length on the telephoto lens
so going from 13 millimeters to 65
millimeters
is actually a five times difference
so that's what he means by the whole
system
providing 5x optical zoom now what's
really weird is that king said that the
pro-max
is getting an expansive ultra wide lens
which to me that basically means it's
going to be wider than 13 millimeters
so in my personal opinion what if king
is actually wrong
because he did say he had trouble
translating it
what if the pro max doesn't actually get
a telephoto lens
with a 65 millimeter focal length what
if
the ultra wide lens is getting wider
with a 10 millimeter lens
and the telephoto stays at 52
millimeters
that basically provides a range of 5x
optical zoom that actually makes a whole
lot more sense to me
because if the ultrawide is getting
wider and the telephoto is getting
longer
that's actually more than 5x so it's
much more likely that
the ultra wide is getting you to the 5x
another benefit that we already knew is
that both of the pro models are getting
the new
lidar scanner which apple is probably
going to be talking
a lot about at this event now by far the
most odd thing that kang said
was that the pro max model is getting a
47
larger sensor than the 6.1 inch pro
model
with the pixel size going up to 1.7
micrometers
now he didn't specify if all three of
the camera sensors are getting larger or
if it's just one of them
but to me it seems pretty weird for the
main wide lens
to be better than on all the other
phones exclusively for the pro max
but one thing to know is that kang
mentioned this difference
on the same line that he mentioned the
pro max getting an expansive
ultra wide lens so if you think about it
if the lens is getting
wider with a 10 millimeter lens it would
make sense to add a larger sensor
with larger pixels for better ultrawide
quality
so what if it's actually the ultra wide
camera sensor that's getting larger
that would actually make more sense
compared to having the pro max getting a
longer 65 millimeter telephoto lens
so i guess we're just gonna have to wait
and see until next week to find out now
a major benefit for all of the models is
that they're going to be able to record
dolby vision video which is basically
the highest standard of hdr video
which further proves that even the
iphone 12 mini
is getting the same great oled xdr
display
which can actually display that dolby
vision footage
in this last bit is perhaps the most
disappointing
he says that we'll only be able to order
the iphone 12 mini
and the iphone 12 pro max in november
with release dates as far away as
november
20th for the pro-max now let's finally
finish
off with some more bad news john prosser
says that apple's air tags
have been delayed until next year
and on top of that the airpods studio
headphones
aren't being revealed at next week's
event and they might even be priced at a
massive
599 dollars now the weird thing is that
apple set the time slot for this
event to two full hours so if they're
not gonna show off both of those
products
what else are they gonna show off well
don't get your hopes up
because more and more leaks and rumors
are pointing to apple
waiting until november to reveal the
apple
silicon max so apple's probably going to
spend a lot of time sweet talking all of
their investors
telling them how they're saving the
world and how everybody is using ios 14
already
and then they're probably gonna spend a
bunch of time talking about new
technology for the iphone 12
like the new lidar scanner and stuff
like that so there you guys go
those are the final iphone 12 leaks
before we report
back to you guys after apple's event on
tuesday
so if you enjoyed this video go ahead
and tap the like button below
click the circle above to subscribe and
check out that video right there
and also check out our merch like this
hoodie right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]